So let's look at the load linked/store
conditional instructions,
which usually we call LL/SC instruction.
We have them because atomic reading and
writing in the same instruction
even if we just do the write, if the
read has tested positive for something.
Is really bad for
pipelining your processor.
Let's look at the classical five stage
pipeline where we fetch the code and
read registers.
Do the area operation.
This is where compute the address for
memory instructions.
Then we have a memory axis stage and
finally, we write the result
to a register, if a register
result exists in the instruction.
Loads will be fetched, decoded and
read the register, compute the address
using that register, access memory to
get the value from that address and
then write the result to a register.
An atomic read/write instruction,
such as a swap, or test and
set, or test and write, would compute
the address and read registers.
And then when it gets
to the memory stage,
it cannot do everything it needs
to do in one access to memory.
because loads and
stores do either a read or a write.
A read/write instruction
needs to do both and
that cannot be done
in the same cycle for
the same memory location without really
complicating the memory stage a lot.
So just for the sake of atomic
read/write instructions, we would need
to add memory 2 stage, possibly memory
3, so that they can read the memory,
do some checking and
then finally write the memory.
So we would be adding to our
pipeline several stages,
possibly, just for
these instructions, but
remember that every instruction flows
through the pipeline the same way.
So if we add these two stages for
these instructions we really have added
two stages for all instructions,
which is not very good.
because these are actually not going to
execute that frequently to justify this.
So we will separate the atomic read and
write into two instructions.
The first will be a load
linked instruction.
Its purpose is to implement the read
part of the atomic operation.
What it does is it behaves
just like a normal load.
It just reads from a memory location and
puts the value in a register.
But in addition to that,
it saves the address from which it
loaded into a special link register.
So that's the only thing that it does
that is different from a normal load.
The store instruction that we
will use to implement the right
part of the atomic read/write operation
is called a store conditional.
What it does is to check first
if the address that it computes
is the same as the one
in the link register.
If the address is the same, then it does
a normal store to that memory location,
and returns a 1 in it's register.
If the address that the store computes
is not the same as the one in the link
register, then it just returns 0 in the
the register without storing anything.
These two are behaving like
a single atomic operation
because of the link register.
So let's see in more
detail how that works.